so I work on I worked on v8 and I now
work on the dart VM and but this is not
why I'm here today and I'm going to talk
about something completely different
though related basically I'm going to
talk to you about how you take your hand
and you stick it into the guts of the VM
where all these sharp things move around
and you get it back and scattered and
another thing I'm going to talk about
today is a very basic thing that all of
us desire desire as strongly as we all
desire lunch that is going to be after
my talk and this thing is toys and some
people call would call things that I
showed you today prototypes mock-ups
mashups experiments but I am calling
them just toys because that's
essentially what I'm having I'm having
some fun and I hope people will have
some fun with them and they will learn
something because that's how you learn
things you play with them and I have
been giving quite a number of talks
about performance and v8 performance
especially and they are all pretty
boring they're all like oh like that
they go and go and can anybody guess the
last line no it's a speculative
optimizations obviously so and the most
amazing thing about such talks is that
people come home and then they heard
about inline caches and they try to see
what inline caches do to their programs
and sorry can't do that you can see
they're like pixie dust that makes
everything fly with the speed of light
but nobody can see it that's a bit
annoying it's it's annoying for people
and gets me very frustrated so I really
wanted to show people how like vm works
and how it optimizes things and let them
observe and when I approach it I have
this principle everybody knows letting
obviously if you translate it from
legend to a current modern language
which is English obviously is that if
you are working on some VM for language
X Y that try to do everything for this
VM in X why's that
that's a lot of fun
and because I follow this principle
everywhere where I go like I worked on
the Java VM I tried to do stuff in Java
I worked on the ADA tried to do more
things in JavaScript I work on Dart
I try to do most things in dart so I I
get some beating for that I think and so
I came up with a plan a the very first
plan that I had and there was also a
little bit in to note at that point so I
just took v8 modified it a little bit
then I took no GS then I connected them
together and let v8 stream data to know
GS and then I connected node.js to the
browser through a WebSockets
oh my god that feels enterprise-e that's
what you deploy in the data center to
make all these millions of people see
what we ate does and if you stop and
think for a moment they're like 3d
eights there at least which is like two
Vav eights too many for this problem so
the plan B is very simple you take one
lonely v8 and put it into a duck place
into the browser modify it a little bit
and let it talk to itself because it's
alone and here is what came out of this
experiment this is code mirror everybody
heard about called mirror I suspect
which is a company in to edit code and
here it shows its own source these
slides are running in the browser it
shows its own source and if I press the
button here not this button this button
then it gets annotated with the state of
inline caches inside the code mirror so
it's showing its own state essentially
the state of the VM on which these
slides are running and I can like this
green okay let me zoom yeah here can you
see it yeah so let me unzoom so this
these things here they show like that
this function has two versions optimize
the non optimized because cold is not
optimized and a little bit warmer color
is optimized and I can like switch
between them like t-this is non
optimized version and it has inline
cache here which is red and red is bad
red is like alarm because it's mega
morphic and I can even click here click
here click yes and I can see assembly
for this stuff which is like the current
state and I am using bootstrap because
I'm do not do any development in the bra
so to show this pop up I use bootstrap
oh my god Jesus Christ
III don't know what I am doing basically
and I can switch to an optimized version
and has green here green is good and
it's a monomorphic thing it says here
store I see monomorphic field here ah
yeah so that's cool that's cool
okay Andrew how do i zoom it like this
yeah so okay cool helps very helpful but
it has one problem so oh now we have a
trouble let me I need I need to hide
this yes and go here oh no don't go here
go here yeah thank you so it has a
problem so on JavaScript site is pretty
easy you expert one function from v8
which is called scripts and allows you
to like pipe out of it the scripts it
knows about and then you can take one
script and ask for inline caches that
are inside the script and then you its
serialized in some form you just realize
it and you show it in this editor cool
but on the other side like in VV 8 you
have a code like that oh my god this is
C++ it's horrible and the biggest
problem is what it's even C++ I would be
upset if it were modular too as well the
biggest problem is that if you want to
extend it a little bit you have to go
this back into v8 and you have to like
hack it with a hammer until it gives you
what you need and then you have to
recompile Chrome and on my laptop it
like it I can fry the eggs when they
recompile Chrome on it so it's a little
bit painful it doesn't allow you to
iterate on features quickly and
everybody tries to iterate a child
basically cool
so and I always have a plan and this is
a plan Z you can you see I tried a
little bit different plans I'm not going
to tell you all like B and D they failed
but this is plan Z it's valid JavaScript
so I take JavaScript and I describe how
objects invade heap look like and I have
this magical function struct which takes
the description of the object which is
the object object literal basically and
it converts it to a function that can
visualize is from the binary stream
and give you back like all these fields
with some like meaningful getters and
setters so if you like ask for size it
will find it in this binary stream and
pick it out of there and I can describe
the heap object I make have inheritance
of strux because that's how obviate
internally represents objects like there
is a heaped object in the root of the
here are here and then you have like map
which is a heap object and you have like
sizes and stuff and given all this stuff
I apply one hammer and one hammer only
on the v8 side well this is another
object we have yeah so this is one
hammer the function heap which returns
you a type to review into v8 heap so you
can just ask you give me all pages in
the v8 heap and it will give you this
huge type arrays which represent v8 heap
and you can read out of them these
objects use my functions to do sterilize
them and inspect them you can like
iterate the heap and take all the
objects there cool and you don't need to
recompile chrome anymore you have one
modified Chrome and you try all that you
want because everything that we need is
in the v8 heap and here is another life
thing embedded into a slide this is like
the first 32 kilobytes of the code space
in the current we it he poo that is
underlined for these slides I can like
look at this and I exceed this some free
space fragmentation a little bit and
it's pretty cool and I can even
disassemble but now that is assembler I
am using I just took some random from
the github written in JavaScript it's
not a v8 assembler any model can
disassemble everything that gate
generates it it's not complete somebody
was not probably wanted to finish it so
it kind of jumble everything but it can
be so simple some stuff like here it
disassembled set correctly for example
and this is great because now I can
iterate stuff and try all things I want
without recompiling chrome but because
it's a typed array view into the v8 heap
I can even write there I can write there
I can take the first page in the heap
and overwrite it with random stuff a lot
of fun and if I press this button I will
I will die in pain now
so you would usually expect I press the
button you will usually expect a set tab
but I have foreseen this and I'm running
in the debugger which unfortunately you
cannot see what the hell I need an zoom
but I cannot turn zoom okay that's
pretty sad isn't it that's that
how do ya but this is X germ can you
imagine that
okay I will be so okay let's do let's be
evil let's be evil I have to be evil and
I cannot see I haven't see yes yes yes
here okay die okay okay here we go
fontsize I I selected a quite a big one
because I knew that you are going to to
want to see it can you see it 30 what do
you want to see 44 24 2008 CVI I hate it
okay okay let's here we go here we go
again yes it is booting up what you know
where is my oh and the light is I kind
of see with my mouse okay here it comes
oh yes yes okay Runyon running here we
are again so and I press the button and
I go here yes we got this sick trap here
and we can like thank you
so they strike the instruction pointer
is now pointing into the baby so we
written stuff everywhere it's awesome
and by quickly bike by coincidence the
size of the string like hello GS conf
new was just enough that if I put in the
beginning this in three instruction
which is a sick trial because it's a
sick trap it precisely execute this
instruction so it doesn't crash at
random stop it Christ from the sick trap
okay so yeah okay yes die no I said die
yes so this guy is dead now I'm sorry
Jim
the bugger is starting again I know and
it starting again I know that's how we
developed chrome by the way so yeah two
tabs prepared for this but because okay
so the question is why we still use it
in C++ if we can do all this awesome
stuff like overwrite memory with random
stuff and stuff yeah so well I have no
idea frankly speaking yeah so yeah so
oh and this is a time yeah I had this
slight embedded to know how long I have
to you can see my transcript skills are
also not so good you don't have a zero
before one awesome clock yeah so this is
another plan which I call no GS and I'm
going to open source it this is not a VM
this is a basically an experiment I'm
trying to do bits of pieces of the VM
like for example I brought this blog
post about how you would try to
implement inline caches in JavaScript
and this is all parts of this like
hidden class is implemented in pure
JavaScript and stuff like that and I'm
trying to understand how these things
fit together so that
in fewer JavaScript it has currently a
pure indication of pure educational
value both for me and for other people
who want to understand how VMs work but
for me it has the educational value
which is like I want to understand if
you can make it work properly to get a
really awesome VM at the end but to do
that I have to do like bits and pieces
separately and here is one of these bits
and pieces in addition to like hidden
class is inline caches I wrote a tracing
cheat for this bytecode and so this is
my god so I don't do parsers language is
a little bit boring for me because like
no they're not boring but I mean you
have to defend them and say there are
list comprehensions in testing that we
all need and all like you do not need
this this is not the comprehension
you're looking for and I don't like that
stuff so I like alright I write code
like that and it's pretty awesome I
think and so if I press this button I
hope nothing will crash but because the
dreamer is just JavaScript for now yeah
here so so the the numbers below is like
70 versus 18 milliseconds 18 is like a
pure JavaScript version of the same code
which is like generate a list of points
and then do a vector sum of this we
really like generating points and
calculating the sum of them in in the VM
guys you have seen the points other
stuff and it's a little bit like three
times slower but actually on the newer
v8 it's like only 1.5 times slower so v8
people fix something and so generates
this trace and the tracing compilers
they like they trace loops and they
generate this linear ir and you can see
what it did with it like how its turn it
into a loop so no Java VM actually uses
it right now like tracing G trace monkey
a little bit diet now they have a method
cheat and this is mostly based on what
for example you can see in lower cheat
and launch it is written and C so if I
go there I like see a lot modular to see
hmm but to understand what he does it's
the easiest way to do it is like
implement everything yourself and I
didn't want to do it and see I wanted to
do it in
our script because other people who can
also see and even if you don't know see
you can understand and you can see oh
you can see the pieces of mac OS you can
see they like generate it's a JavaScript
function out of these and it has like
the optimizations well this is a check
and the optimization all the stuff you
can see in a normal VM and you can learn
from this and but now somebody can say
ok this is pretty cool but JavaScript
I mean you now go to the kindergarten
and in Germany and they generate
JavaScript all day long basically and
this is not so cool and really I mean
you are like 26 years old and you still
with this stuff so I thought yeah that's
true that's true
and let's generate some assembly this is
not assembly I'm not going to save it
yeah so this is it runs inside node as
well yeah ok let me make it smaller
smaller unzoom yes so obviously how do
you start writing a compiler generates
assembly you start like doing like her
awesome blah awesome blah yeah here it
comes yeah if I start like that we were
probably like I would have to change my
ticket back to or who's on a little bit
later date and you will have to stay in
this bubble for longer time so I'm not
going to do that wait a second wait a
second wait for a punchline so and also
it's pretty hard to understand if you
just coming in and like assembler you
need to do like register allocator all
this cool stuff but a little bit boring
for five minutes
and so I thought about that and I said
oh wait a second let's tap to the power
the power and the power we have access
to is áliveá so I took a lot of iam and
I bounded to note well strictly speaking
I took si Lang and I bounded to note and
then I used that to generate bindings
for LLVM and then I said okay you these
bindings are pretty cool but I cannot
work with like v8 Hiba I saw this all
exists in v8 keep all these objects and
I thought maybe I should be very evil
how about I just stick my hand into v8
hip and I start messing with objects
like I want to do it and sir all this
module based on the LLVM Levin sheet
because I have only five minutes and
even despite that I have all the code
like in snippets in the editor I don't
want to type it yes so let's let's be
cheating let's be cheating so we do like
CD engine awesome
yes okay yes I want to reload this I was
very fast to write this code huh how
about that so so I have this code the
module called Mel door because it sounds
very evil and it does very evil stuff
Mel dot so what man and I also used
wheels because this makes me feel like
very very evil can you see it actually I
hope you see so I create this guy called
Mel door and he can like access directly
like arguments like in v8 if you ever
used like nodejs you know this v8 : :
argument subject and then you need to
cooperate her son need but it allows you
just basically go in and stick your hand
and take whatever you want like a
democracy and and basically you can see
so yeah you know the first argument then
you like take the zeros property of
wheat and taken elements of this
property and you take like property with
number two and you take the pro argument
with number one and you take elements
from it and then you create a translator
a translator sounds little bit evil as
well and the translator is like the
generic way to translate their of my
tracing compiler I R stands for the
intermediate representation internal
representation whatever you want it to
stand for so and it has like a little
bit of points where you can tweak it and
translate it to anything like two IR of
the LLVM for example like need to
translate like a literal we need to
translate the constants which are pretty
simple because meld allows you to do
that and you need like and the tracing
Gir is very simple it's like a linear
sequence of code a preheater for the
and then you have a loop body and that's
all no conditions only side exits and so
to translate the loop it's pretty simple
just create like another block and you
enter it and then you need to translate
five functions and then you need to
connect the back edge to the loop loop
is done and that translate function is
very boring like you take things and you
translate them let's check something
simple for example check in is the one
the checks number and basically ton
boxes the number so Mel do like gives
you unbox number which takes a v8 number
and haba you get the double out of it
and all I can box 32-bit integer or like
take this like a pointer to the field
and stuff like that so it's very very
straightforward multiply numbers and
like yeah it allows you to build
conditionals very simple like you just
say if not value do these otherwise do
nothing return so a very basic very
basic and then you this dollar I wanted
it to look like jQuery to make it very
attractive everybody's going to use
everybody is going to use it yeah and so
then you ask the evil guy to melt stuff
meld it now and it is done it is done
and let's see how it works so here I
have a node and if I run who is like no
LLVM it runs like 72 milliseconds
compute some number if I run with LLVM
it runs in 32 milliseconds whoo ha
almost as fast maybe a little bit faster
than the latest v8 and now somebody who
can say I think you're cheating because
you're Russian and some people say that
actually you will not believe that so
let's make sure that let's make sure
that I'm not cheating though you can't
prove it
I had a debug break so melted also
allows you to insert the entry
instruction directly into the code you
January so I run like that okay let's
make it bigger I run it and there is a
sick trap and I can disassemble from
here sorry
not zero of course cannot access so this
is the code which Mehldau generated for
off function written in this bytecode
traced through my compiler and then
compiles through LLVM and they transform
the node so you can actually use it for
doing some useful stuff maybe thank you
that's I think well I'm writing on time
anyways yes so yeah so the slowdown is
mostly because v8 I use intentionally a
non efficient representation compared to
the a too many in directions does not
matter okay and of course in the limit I
wanted to become a real VM as I said I
like mathematics as well so there is
also some stuff can you spot a bark I
hope you cannot draw so this is the plan
Omega it doesn't matter what the plan is
it doesn't help to understand VMs thank
you
now you can ask some questions but I
will not answer you can just skip lunch
hey I just I just looked in NPM and I
don't see meld oh yeah
I will publish yeah I hope I will
publish today yeah everything will be
open source here someday when I'm 70
years old so instead of executing it in
the sea level in in via NVH which is get
a source and then write an interpreter
for the assembly basically run v8 on its
own code that gets executed in v8 again
with this isn't it what it does every it
runs v8 on the codes yeah and then this
kind of thing yeah sure everything
supposed to I didn't understand the
question but I think everything is
possible
okay thank you very much